foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
Magic Johnson is partnered with Coke
Zero sugar for a new March Madness
inspired TV commercial launch campaign
alongside Tamika Catchings uh Little
Dicky uh Travis Bennett AKA taco and
Magic Johnson joining us on the program
when was the last time you played pickup
basketball
laughs
oh my goodness Dan it's been a long a
lot of years man I I probably
seven eight nine ten years but do you
miss do you shoot around at all
yeah yeah I shoot around but I don't
play pickup anymore uh I the fun comes
when the the great thing is the gym that
I work out every morning at uh has a a
full court basketball court so I'm able
to go in there and shoot because I work
out so early so a lot of people are not
there so that works out because I love
to shoot matter of fact you know some
days I just go in there and shoot for
like a half hour 45 minutes but I
wondered how you would be given
everybody has to shoot the three or once
to shoot the three now how do you think
your game would be in you know in the
modern era or today
oh it wouldn't change any because what I
do what I specialize in is still is
needed in the game today that's coming
down on that fast break and passing it
to people and putting them in the
position to score so now instead of
shooting uh passing it uh to the guys
that they can do the slam dunk or the
layup I'll be passing it for them to
shoot the three-point shot so and then
you have to remember Sinners are not
Sinners so when I play you had at least
two seven Footers almost on the court
now you don't have that so man I'll be
driving that to that back
and I don't I won't have no resistance
in today's game right but what do you
think you could have averaged if you
wanted to
wait and playing if I was just an
offensive minded guy yeah let's say you
were you had the green light like Jordan
did
oh yeah well I probably wouldn't average
as much as him but I I could have
averaged 28 29 30 points a game that was
easy I did that my whole career in High
School uh I could have did that at
Michigan State too but it's not about
that for me it what it was about was I
wanted to win so when I saw that we had
scores like Jamal and Kareem and Norm
when I got to the Lakers I just said hey
I want to win so I just said I'm on
whatever I need to score to help us win
that's what I'm going to do and so when
Pat Riley finally gave me the green
light when kareema had got older you
know my years now I'm averaging 24 25
points a game I could have did that when
I walked in and so uh but it's about
winning I I didn't care about that and
even today I still don't care I just
want to win I I want to win you know so
so I've always been like that and I will
always be like that is it possible
Kareem is underrated
oh for sure
you know we have to remember that Kareem
is the most decorated winner
in basketball history there's nobody can
has a resume right from high school on
there's nobody think about everything
that he did he won almost every state
championship in high school he won every
National Championship in college and was
it a college player of the year every
single year and he would have won four
if freshmen were allowed to play
uh at that time like it you know I could
I could play as a freshman in the NCAA
he couldn't do that he had to wait till
the next year so when I think about his
full resume right uh there's no no
greater winner uh
uh probably him and Bill Russell would
be the two dudes who have had the most
decorated career in terms of winning
if not Michigan State where were you
going
uh Michigan probably because remember
they had just played in 1978.
uh they had just I'm sorry 1977 excuse
me uh Michigan and Indiana Indiana had
played for the national championship
that's the last time a team I think was
undefeated when Indiana and Bobby Knight
had uh they had I think it was 32-0 I
believe and so they played Michigan
though for the championship right that's
the last time two teams from the same
conference ended up in a championship so
Michigan was my second choice uh but uh
I'm glad I chose the green and white in
Michigan State if I would have switched
you and Larry Bird and you played for
Indiana State and Larry played for
Michigan State who would have won that
national title
wow now you know Dan I'm not gonna sit
here and say I would have lost any game
okay
I just thought
you know he and he would say the same to
you right if you asked him the same
thing if he had went to Michigan State
he gonna say he would do well and I'm
gonna say the same thing I would have
did well at Indiana State uh now if he
would have played with great kelser in
that Championship wow
we would have had a hard time beating
him probably because people forget that
great capsule was really special did you
understand the Magna like what you and
Larry were bringing together in that
national title game and then later took
it to the NBA
I I don't think we understood Dan until
after you know when we when they told us
it was a it's it's it had been and still
is the number one watch game in college
basketball history you know
we we knew it was special because he you
know they were undefeated and he was
college basketball player of the year
and I was runner up to that right I
think it was the first time Dan that two
guys
uh the two best players met for
the national championship
but when did you realize you two were
alike
oh I mean that
listen I knew that in college I and and
and and then when we got into the pros
it just really put the stamp of approval
on that that the fact that we were so
much alike and then when we shot a
commercial because we in the early
beginning we hated each other you know
we had to because uh he ended up on the
celt as I end up on the Lakers and so
you knew that there was going to be
um you know hatreds there because the
Celtics had beat the Lakers what I think
seven straight times I believe and so uh
and then we met and then they beat us in
84. so we had to I had to hate him I had
to hate the Celtics and then when we
shot that commercial I believe in 87 uh
in at his house in French slick Indiana
that's when we became friends and that's
when we finally said you know what we're
more alike than we are different because
we're both Midwest boys we're close to
our family uh we we
also changed the game of basketball
together
whether that was in college or the NBA
and then we always were about making our
teammates better right we we were we
rather pass than shoot a lot of times
and so the two big guys that can handle
the basketball that would do anything to
win and so uh you know I just I love
Larry Bird that's my man and so uh I
think the thing that is special then was
that he made me better and I made him
better and so uh and that's why I think
then even when I think about what's
happening right now right this campaign
is happening over March Madness right
the Coke Zero Zero sugar
uh is going on March Madness it's going
to be amazing uh Dave and Travis are two
cool guys who we shot this commercial
for Coke Zero sugar in a bodega and uh
what are we talking about right who's
the best ever just like you and I just
talk about Larry and myself and uh what
team was the best and was Kareem the
best uh we had that same debate uh uh in
this commercial and then I show up when
Dave and Travis are having that debate I
show up and uh and really grabbed the
Coke Zero sugar and walk out and it's
it's amazing commercial I'm happy that
I'm doing it and I'm happy that it's
Aaron doing March Madness too yeah it's
uh gonna air for the first time during
Duke and North Carolina Dave Byrd and
Travis Bennett Tamika Catchings we're
talking to Magic Johnson it's a
Coca-Cola zero sugar ads featuring uh
Magic and Company did you did you have
to hate Michael Jordan as well that you
said you had to hate Larry Bird
I I didn't get a chance to hate Michael
uh
because of the fact that you know we
play one time
I think because of the relationship with
Larry happened in college in terms of us
Indiana State Michigan State then it
carried over to the two most storied
franchises in NBA history the Celtics
and the Lakers and we played so many
times that's why I think we hated each
other and disliked each other in terms
of the Celtics Lake of Larry and I
Michael I think the dislike might have
came more the Bulls and Celtics right
because they're in Eastern Conference
and they played so many times but we
only really uh you know that one time in
91 when they won when they beat us and
so
um I didn't have a chance to hate
Michael but we're good friends and uh I
love MJ and and what he stands for what
he's built not only on the court but off
the court his business uh so it's great
can LeBron surpass Michael in your eyes
um I don't know I don't know he it might
takes it might take a couple more
championships to do that
um
LeBron is special and and I don't want
people to always get mad over you know
we had to celebrate both guys I mean
Michael is the best and we should
celebrate him and we should celebrate
LeBron and so uh I hate when people get
mad at you if you take one or the other
and uh we should just say hey Michael is
special and I always say
he's special because and he's the best
to me because he never lost in the NBA
finals and he's averaged over 37 points
a game I mean the guy is just
unbelievable and so uh but LeBron is
special too in his own right too and uh
um and people shouldn't forget that
either but when it all said if you come
at me and you ask me that's who I'm
gonna go with is MJ uh magic thank you
and good luck with the campaign great to
talk to you again
you too Dan take care of yourself
brother Magic Johnson partnered with uh
Coke Zero sugar a new March Madness
inspired TV commercial and uh always
good to talk to